dragon
spacex bestätigte display sind
für den
start konfiguriert spacex dragon display sind für den start konfiguriert
papi bob doug im namen des gesamten
spacex-teams war es mir eine große ehre, ihnen
bei der vorbereitung auf die heutige historische mission zu helfen
wissen sie, dass wir mit ihnen einen fantastischen
flug haben  und genieße diese ansichten unseres
wunderschönen planeten
danke jay äh es ist absolut unsere
ehre teil dieser äh
riesigen bemühungen zu sein um die vereinigten staaten
wieder in das startgeschäft zu bringen äh
wir werden aus dem orbit mit dir sprechen danke
kopie alles danke dafür  Wörter
beginnend mit tvc hydraulische Presse
Stufe eins und Stufe zwei Motorkühlung hat
begonnen
Motorhydraulik Hochdruck
und Stufe eins Kraftstoff ist geschlossen
Falcon 9 ist nicht selbstausgerichtet
Falcon 9 Heizungen schließen
Dragon hat umgestellt, um für
Terminal Count zu
konfigurieren Tanks drücken oder  starker Rückzug
starker Rückzug hat begonnen
Stufe 2 rb1 bluten
Seite 1 U / min führen
achtern endgültige Einrichtung gestartet m Beutelzünder spült, obwohl Blutdrache
h  wie auf Terminal
Count umgeschaltet und auf interner
Leistungsstufe 1 gesperrt
Ladeabschluss Fahrzeug wechselt auf interne
Leistungsstufe 2 Sperre Schwimmer wird pro
Pfund Füllungen abgeschlossen
Drachen ist ein automatischer Leerlauf
Braun Gasabschlüsse startet
Falke 9 ist im Startdrachen  ist kein
countdown fts ist
bereit für den start drache spacex start
start spacex drache wir gehen zum start lass
uns diese kerze spielen
t minus 30 sekunden
stufe eins panzer pressen für flug team
ist 15 sekunden
zehn neun acht sieben
sechs fünf vier drei
zwei eins  Zero Ignition
Liftoff of the Falcon 9 und Crew Dragon
Go NASA Go Spacex Got Speed Spot und Dog Vehic
e Pitching Downrange One Alpha Copy
ne Alpha Stage One Antrieb ist nomin
l Falco
Power Intellektuell nominal m1d D
osselung Fahrz
ug ist Überschall und eins drosseln Sie max K
ll  ein bravo
kopieren ein bravo
start von mvac motorkühlung
m1d drosseln
mvac zündung
erfassung von signalwellen
stufe zwei antrieb ist nominell
Dragon Spacex nominelle Flugbahn
Erfassung von Signal und Bermuda Spacex
Dragon nominelle Flugbahn
Phase zwei Antrieb ist immer noch nominell
Dragon spacex nominelle Flugbahn
nominelle Flugbahn
zur
Erdatmosphäre und dann nach dem
Eintrittsbrand wird die Landung brennen,
die nur eine einzelne Spacex nominelle
Flugbahn
und Sie ist  Ich habe nominelle Startkinder gehört,
da ist dieser Ruf, sie sind immer
noch nominell
auf der zweiten Stufe, und das ist, dass der
hintere Motor auf der zweiten Stufe auf Ihrem linken
Bildschirm
wieder auf Ihrem rechten Bildschirm ist, dass der
Booster der ersten Stufe zurück
zu unserem Drohnenschiff kommt, natürlich i  Ich
liebe dich immer noch, wir sind ungefähr eine Minute vom
Eintritt entfernt,
während die zweite Stufe
den Drachen wieder in die Umlaufbahn
treibt, wenn du den
Timer im Auge behältst, der bis zum Flug nach
acht Minuten und 44 Sekunden
weiterbrennen wird,
also a  in etwas mehr als zwei minuten
hören wir den ruf seco
, dann wird es ein bisschen gut,
etwas mehr als drei mi  Nutes, bis sich der Drache
physisch von der zweiten
Stufe des Falken 9
nach dem Aufstand trennt spacex nominelle
Flugbahn Die nominelle Flugbahn des
Drachen Tappy wird
weiterhin bei Bob und Doug einchecken,
da sie sich auf einer nominellen Flugbahn befinden, die
nur etwa 10 Sekunden von dieser ersten Stufe entfernt ist,
die diesen Eintrag beginnt  Brennen auf Ihrem rechten
Bildschirm sollten wir in der Lage sein zu sehen, dass Sie live sehen können, dass
die
Stufe 1 des Eintrags brennt.
Beginnen Sie mit
diesem Brennen. Beginnen Sie mit diesem Brennen. Diese Verbrennung dauert etwa 36 Sekunden.
Stufe 2 Fuß ist sicher. Nun,
dass der Eintrag brennen dauert
Abseits von Ceco werden
wir eine Reihe von Ereignissen haben, die alle
schnell hintereinander passieren, das wird der
zweite Triebwerksabbruch
für die Landung der ersten Stufe sein, kurz
danach,
eigentlich nur innerhalb weniger Sekunden,
so eine coole Ansicht auf Ihrem linken Bildschirm, die Sie
sehen  bob und doug
auf dem drachen gerade jetzt können sie die bildschirme sehen, die
sie
gerade selbst sehen endführung
und rückgasschritt
wir kommen 25 sek  Onds oder so entfernt
von Seco oder Second Engine Cut Off,
dies ist auch der Punkt, an dem Bob und
Doug ihre höchste
G-Kraft erfahren. Wir sehen, wie der Zähler
etwa
einen Punkt nach rechts tickt. Kopieren Sie Shannon, Sie haben Shannon gehört
,
das bedeutet nur sie  Sie befinden sich in ihren endgültigen
Abbruchzonen, wenn sie an
diesem Punkt
abbrechen würden, aber entweder in den Orbit abbrechen oder
vor der Küste Irlands landen und auf die
zweite
Bestätigung und den Vektorschritt warten
und die digitale
Landeschichtbestätigung des zweiten Triebwerks von ceco abschalten  Abgeschnitten
jetzt warten wir darauf, dass unsere erste
Stufe ihren Weg zu unserem Drohnenschiff findet.
Natürlich liebe ich immer noch Dragon Spacex
Nominal Orbital Insertion.
Was Sie auf Ihrem Bildschirm sehen, ist eine
Live-Ansicht unseres Drohnenschiffs,
wo unsere erste Stufe sein wird  Das
Herunterkommen
sieht so aus, als hätten wir diese Live-Ansicht verloren, aber
wir werden in Kürze auf die Bestätigung dieser Landung warten.
Hier ist
Falcon 9 First Aid erfolgreich gelandet,
und dort können Sie auf Ihrem Bildschirm sehen, dass
Falcon 9 gelandet ist  Der erste
Falke 9, der
Menschen in die Umlaufbahn befördert hat, ist für uns sehr aufregend,
und wie Sie auf Ihrem rechten Bildschirm sehen können, machen sich
Bob und Doug immer
noch auf den Weg in ihre
Zielumlaufbahn. Jemand braucht eine Erholung
Hör auf, alles
klar, wir haben, wir haben wieder gehört, dass
gute orbitale Einfügung ausgerufen wurde, also bedeutet das, dass
Falcon 9 und Drache genau jetzt genau
dort sind, wo sie sein sollen,
und wir brauchen eine FRC für die Erholung und
es ist genau bei etwa 12 Minuten,
wenn Drache  Sieht so aus, als hätten wir einen
Null-G-Indikator gesehen, der dort
herumschwebte. Ich weiß, Bob und Doug schulden uns
ein wenig darüber, was genau das ist
, was sie mit sich gebracht haben,
und bevor die Trennung beginnt, bevor der Drache
die Trennung von der zweiten Stufe einleitet
, stellen sie sicher, dass sie dies tun  Stellen Sie sicher, dass das
Fahrzeug nicht schleudert und in gutem
Zustand ist, bevor wir es trennen. Das ist
richtig. Die obere Stufe führt
kleine Lagemanöver mit Kaltgas-
Triebwerken durch,
die in den Raketenkörper selbst eingebaut sind,
genau so wie wir es tun  Erwarten Sie, dass die
Trennung in etwa einer Minute von jetzt an erfolgt, aber
sie warten, bis sie die vollständige
Bestätigung haben, dass sie bereit ist,
solche coolen Ansichten zu trennen. Ich kann diese
Ansicht nicht überwinden, die
wir gerade auf dem rechten Bildschirm im Inneren sehen
Besatzungsdrachen
draußen im Weltraum Ja, schon
200 Kilometer über dem Planeten Erde oder
etwas mehr als 124 Meilen
mit mehr als 2.700 Metern
27.000 Meter pro Sekunde oder etwa 16.000
Meilen pro Stunde,
wieder stehen wir nur daneben, dass das
Trennungsereignis kommen sollte  In
Kürze werden
sie mit einer Reihe von Überprüfungen
der Draco-Triebwerke beginnen,
die zum Manövrieren verwendet werden,
und dann den Drachen auf seinem
Flug zur internationalen Raumstation
antreiben, der für die Trennung
bereitsteht  erwartet los
Signalverlust mit einer der Bodenstationen
wartet jetzt auf Bestätigung dieser
Drachentrennung bestätigt
Drachentrennung bestätigt es gibt eine
großartige Sicht direkt vor der Tür  von euch
und da ist dieser ruf drache macht sich jetzt
offiziell auf den weg zur
internationalen
raumstation heute
dragon spacex mit diesem trennungsruf
haben wir ein paar worte von unserem
falcon 19
für sie  im namen des gesamten
startteams vielen dank, dass sie heute mit falcon 9 geflogen
sind. wir hoffen, sie haben die fahrt genossen und
wünschen ihnen eine großartige mission.
danke paula
harte
arbeit und äh danke für die tolle äh fahrt zum
space
guppy, ich bin sehr stolz auf euch und
der rest des team
vielen dank für das, was sie
heute für uns getan haben, indem sie amerika
vom florida-coast-
guppy zurück in die niedrige erdumlaufbahn gebracht haben  viel glück viel glück
alles klar also bob und doug sind in dragon
spacex wir bestätigen die nominelle eclipse
aktivierung und
den serviceabschnitt  Erz hier in Hawthorne gibt der
Crew eine Warnung,
dass wir die Bestätigung haben, dass der Nasenkegel eingesetzt
wird, also wird sich der
Nasenkegel wieder etwas mehr als
90 Grad öffnen, bis zu etwa 105
Grad
, glaube ich, und das wird das freilegen  der eigentliche
Andockring und die Luke, durch die sie
gehen werden, sobald sie
an der internationalen Raumstation befestigt sind,
und auch vier dieser Draco-
Triebwerke, wir nennen sie die Vorwärtsschott-
Triebwerke, die
sie für diese großen
Phasenverbrennungen oder verwenden werden  Das Abfeuern dieser
Triebwerke, um ihre Umlaufbahn
in den kommenden Stunden allmählich anzuheben,
hörte auch eine gute Aktivierung der Sonnenfinsternis
, die das Umweltkontroll- und
Lebenserhaltungssystem ist, das alles ist, was
ihre Atmosphäre kontrolliert,
nur um den Drachen eine schöne, sichere und
bewohnbare Umgebung zu erhalten,
in der sie leben werden  für die
nächsten 19 Stunden, bis sie punktgenau an der
Raumstation ankommen und der Job von Falcon 9
für heute erledigt sein mag, aber die Mission ist nein
Die Arbeit von Over Crew Dragon ist noch nicht erledigt, da Sie sehen können,
dass Bob und Doug
immer noch in Crew Dragon sind und sich auf
den Weg machen. Es wird eine 19-stündige Reise
zur internationalen Raumstation sein,
bevor sie morgen früh andocken,
und so coole Aussichten, die ich liebe, dass wir können
Holen Sie sich diese Live-Ansichten hier
und sehen und beobachten Sie, was sie jetzt
tun, wo sie
sich im Orbit befinden. Ja, es ist unglaublich
, ihnen einfach über die Schulter zu schauen,
um mitzufahren,
und wir werden mit ihnen sein und
wir sind es  Sie alle werden den
ganzen
Weg bis zur Raumstation begleiten, die
wir
während der ganzen Zeit live übertragen werden. Bob und Doug werden
offensichtlich eine Schlafphase haben,
in der sie
etwas später heute ungefähr acht Stunden schlafen werden  Bevor
sie für ihren endgültigen Anflug aufwachen, ist
eines der wichtigsten Dinge, auf die wir
uns in den nächsten Stunden freuen,
ihre erste Runde an den
Kontrollen,
also werden sie tatsächlich
diese Touchscreen-Displays verwenden
Kontrolle  und Drachen manuell steuern,
wir führen Sie durch, wie das
aussehen wird, und unter der Annahme, dass wir eine
gute Bodenstationsabdeckung haben, werden wir in der
Lage sein, Ansichten
direkt aus dem Inneren des Drachen zu bekommen, der ihnen über
die Schulter schaut, während sie die
Steuerelemente am Display manipulieren,
aber  Ich meine, wir hatten eine reibungslose Fahrt
bergauf, beide Stufen der Falcon 9
, die ihre Arbeit erledigten, indem sie Bob und Doug
in die Umlaufbahn
brachten. Ich meine, dies ist ein Tag. Dies ist ein
historischer Tag
Alle reden
und sehnen sich nach dem Ende des Space-Shuttle-
Programms im Jahr 2011.
Und das Wetter, das Wetter spielte
ja mit, das
zweite Mal ist ein Zauber,
richtig, also Tag für die Geschichtsbücher,
wie Sie sehen,
haben wir einige verloren  Live-Signal dort, aber die
Mission geht
noch weiter und wir werden
es an
ksc um senden, um weiterhin Live-
Signale zu übertragen, Neufundland,
ja, Jesse und Dan, wir sind einfach nur ehrfürchtig
hier drüben und ich bin heute Morgen aufgewacht und
siehe da  ok bei der wettervorhersage war ich
wie
mann, wir werden am sonntag wieder hier sein,
aber wir haben es geschafft
und der raum wurde ausgeräumt, alle sahen
draußen zu
und drinnen die lichter zitterten die
kameras zitterten lauren kam
zurück  Tränen in ihren Augen,
äh, das ist wirklich erstaunlich,
ich kann es nicht glauben, ich habe es mit meinen
eigenen Augen gesehen, das ist,
ich bin ein bisschen sprachlos, ähm, einfach so
dankbar,
dass wir sie da oben hingebracht haben, und es gibt noch
viel mehr
zu tun  viel mehr zu tun, aber ich bin so glücklich, dass
sie gerade in Sicherheit sind. Ich bin einfach so glücklich.
Ja, Leland, Sie haben darüber gesprochen.
Es ist erstaunlich, was
wir tun können, wenn wir zusammenarbeiten, ja,
amerikanische Astronauten, die eine amerikanische
Rakete von amerikanischem Boden
zeigen  Sie, was Amerikaner tun können, wenn
wir als Team zusammenkommen
und Doug in die Luft jagen und in den Kosmos abheben,
darum geht es und ihre
Familien und alle arbeiten
zusammen, um sie sicher in den Weltraum zu bringen
, also i '  m
ich weiß nicht was ich sagen soll ich bin diese rakete
f  uel ist immer noch
in meinen venen und ähm ich will auf
den felsen gehen
gut es ist jetzt zu spät vielleicht der
nächste aber wir wollen rüber gehen zu ähm daryl
bei osb2
er ist dort mit dem administrator der
hoffentlich mehr worte hat als  das tun wir,
weil wir immer noch irgendwie sprachlos sind
daryl
unglaublich hier marie im
Betriebsunterstützungsgebäude,
wo
seit Beginn des Starts ein Applaus erklang, und
während der verschiedenen Phasen waren
einige ganz besondere Gäste hier,
um es zu sehen, einschließlich Präsident Donald
Trump-
Vizepräsident Mike Pence und NASA-
Administrator
Jim Bridenstine, der sich mir jetzt anschließt, und Sie
waren mit dem Präsidenten
und dem Vizepräsidenten Amerika ist zurück,
um wieder menschliche Astronauten zu starten, sagen Sie mir,
wie Sie darüber denken,
und erzählen Sie mir, wie der Präsident
den Start beobachtete und was passiert ist
Also, das hat lange auf sich warten lassen, ähm,
es ist neun Jahre her, seit wir
amerikanische Astronauten auf amerikanischen Raketen
von amerikanischem Boden aus gestartet haben,
und jetzt i  es ist fertig wir haben
es geschafft es ist viel zu lange her ich
möchte charlie bolden viel lob zollen er war
mein vorgänger als nasa-administrator
er hat hart für dieses programm gekämpft zu einer
zeit als es keine unterstützung
im kongress fand
Wir haben jetzt eine Verwaltung,
die unsere Raumfahrtinitiativen voll und ganz unterstützt,
nicht nur bei der
Erkundungsentdeckung zum Mond oder zum
Mars, sondern auch
aus Sicht der Weltraumstreitkräfte
steigen
unsere
Budgets  Nur ein erstaunlicher Tag. Sie wissen, dass
der Präsident,
als er
Präsident wurde, von Anfang an den sogenannten National
Space Council gründete
und den Vizepräsidenten zum
Vorsitzenden des National Space Council
und in diesen National Space Council ernannte
Sie haben den Verteidigungsminister
und den Außenminister und den
Handelsminister, den
Verkehrsminister, den
Bildungsminister,
den Vorsitzenden der Joint Chiefs
Diese verschiedenen erstaunlichen Personen, die
sich Tag für Tag mit Weltraum befassen,
viele Menschen wissen nicht, wie viele
Teile der Bundesregierung sich
mit Weltraum befassen, und der Vizepräsident hat
diese Mitglieder des nationalen
Weltraumrates auch hierher eingeladen, also hatten
wir es gerade  und dann hatten wir Mitglieder des
Kongresses überparteiliche Mitglieder des Kongresses
Republikaner und Demokraten
, die an der Unterstützung
dieses Programms
beteiligt waren
Ich werde Ihnen auch sagen, dass ich nicht
feiern werde, bis Bob und Doug
morgen sicher zu Hause sind. Sie werden
heute Abend an der Internationalen Raumstation andocken. Ich
fliege nach Houston
, um im Johnson Space Center zu sein,
wenn das passiert, so
ist es  Es ist ein bisschen eine Erleichterung, dass
der Nasenkonus jetzt offen ist,
ähm, er ist jetzt eingesetzt, ähm, was bedeutet,
ähm,
Sie wissen, jetzt werden wir
einige Verbrennungen bekommen, wir werden
einige phasenweise Verbrennungen haben, die wir haben werden  etwas
ähm  Einige, die
Sie kennen, steigern Verbrennungen und
wir werden so viel wie möglich in Übereinstimmung
mit der internationalen Raumstation bringen,
ähm so früh wie möglich hier, aber auch ähm,
ich weiß, es ist schwer, aber Sie wissen, das
Wichtigste, was wir jetzt tun müssen, ist
Wir müssen Bob und Doug holen, die
diese Übung jetzt zweimal gemacht haben, sie
müssen sich etwas ausruhen,
ähm, aber ich kann Ihnen garantieren, dass es
für eine ganze Weile keine Ruhe geben wird,
während
sie dort oben im Orbit sind, und das sind sie
sicherlich auf dem Weg und viele
Leute, die sich uns für diese
gesamte Feier anschließen und zuschauen, wir hörten gerade
10 Millionen Menschen, die live zusahen, als dieser
Start
stattfand, und Präsident Donald Trump
wurde der dritte
amtierende Präsident, der zuerst einen Start live
vom Kennedy Space Center aus verfolgte
Seien Sie klar, ich denke, er ist der
einzige amtierende Präsident
, der amerikanischen Astronauten beim Start auf einer
brandneuen Rakete zusieht, die noch nie zuvor gestartet wurde,
und ähm, das ist ein großes Risiko. Sie wissen, dass er
auch gesagt hat, wir werden zum Mond fliegen
bis 2024. Das bedeutet, dass
er sich dem Risiko aussetzt zu sagen: Schau,
ich werde möglicherweise verantwortlich sein, ich werde
für die Initiativen verantwortlich sein, die ich
vorschlage, und ich denke, dafür
hatten wir diese Art von Führung nicht
Raum in einer sehr, sehr langen Zeit und
äh
und wir sind so dankbar dafür, wie war es
, den Start des
Präsidenten zu beobachten, wie hat er reagiert,
oh, ich sage Ihnen, es ist offensichtlich
etwas,
das ihm sehr am Herzen liegt, er hat es gesagt
Vor anderthalb Jahren hat er es in die Rede zum Stand der Gewerkschaft gebracht, in der
er sagte,
wir werden amerikanische Astronauten auf
amerikanischen Raketen
von amerikanischem Boden aus starten, und natürlich
dachte ich mir, ich denke, wir sollten es
besser tun  Wir sollten das besser hinter uns bringen
und natürlich haben wir
Überstunden gemacht
, um das zu erreichen. Wir sind vielleicht etwas
hinter dem Zeitplan zurück,
aber wir haben es geschafft und wir haben es
sicher geschafft. Wir klopfen auf Holz,
aber aber  so weit so gut es sieht gut aus für
dich persönlich jim
als die rakete abhob  und du hast
dieses rumpeln gespürt ja was
hast du gefühlt was hast du erlebt
gut ich habe gebetet ich werde dich nicht anlügen
ich habe gebetet ich habe für
bob und doug gebetet ich habe für ihre
familien
gebetet ich habe für ihre gebetet  Sichere Rückkehr,
obwohl sie gerade gehen,
aber Mann, ich sage dir, es war, äh, ich
habe dieses Rumpeln schon einmal gehört, aber es ist ein
ganz anderes Gefühl, wenn du
dein eigenes Team auf dieser Rakete hast und
sie unser Team sind  sind Amerikas
Team,
das ist der Start von Amerika, das ist
alles, was Amerika in seiner reinsten Form zu bieten hat,
und die Zeiten sind gerade hart,
es besteht kein Zweifel, dass
wir die Coronavirus-Pandemie haben, wir
haben andere Herausforderungen als Land,
aber ich hoffe, dass dieser Moment kommt  Zeit ist eine
Gelegenheit für alle,
über die Menschheit nachzudenken und darüber, was wir tun können, wenn
wir zusammenarbeiten,
wenn wir uns bemühen und wenn wir etwas
erreichen, und ob dies ein kleines Kind dazu inspirieren kann,
der nächste Elon Musk oder
der nächste Jeff
Bezos oder der nächste zu werden  Sir Richard Branson
dann das'  Darum geht es hier oder um
den nächsten Jim Bridenstine. Ja,
ich würde mich nicht in diese Kategorie einordnen,
aber wir schätzen Ihre Führung für
die Raumfahrtbehörde zu diesem Zeitpunkt
und gratulieren Ihnen zu einem fantastischen Tag
beim Start.
Danke, es war eine großartige Fahrt  In
Ordnung, sehr gut, Marie, wir schicken
es dir ins Studio zurück.
Doug und Bob sind auf dem Weg,
morgen, den
31. Mai,
um 10.27 Uhr östlicher Zeit auf der Internationalen Raumstation anzukommen, und wir
bleiben durchgehend live auf Sendung  Berichterstattung über die
gesamte Fahrt zur Station.
Obwohl unsere Berichterstattung hier endet, werden
wir sie an die
Teams in Hawthorne und Houston übergeben, um
uns durch
die nächsten Phasen der Demo 2-Mission
bis hin zum Öffnen der Luke
und einer Willkommenszeremonie zu führen  Die
Raumstation für Bob und Doug morgen
, das ist richtig, und wenn Sie uns folgen,
laden wir Sie ein, sich an einer Pressekonferenz nach dem Start zu
beteiligen
, die heute
Abend um 6.30 Uhr östlicher Zeit hier
im NASA-Fernsehen stattfindet. Wir haben die NASA  und Spacex-
Führer hier, um
Fragen zu dieser beispiellosen
Errungenschaft in der bemannten Raumfahrt live zu beantworten,
und zusätzlich zu NASA-TV können Sie
immer
auf Twitter unter NASA und NASA.gov folgen,
um Missions-Updates zu erhalten, während sie fortschreitet.
Hier sind jetzt die Höhepunkte der
bisherigen Mission
30. Mai 2020 erinnere dich an diesen Tag
, du wirst diese Erinnerung für immer haben,
der Tag
, an dem Amerika Astronauten von US-Boden in die Umlaufbahn zurückbrachte
[Musik] nun,
wir schreiben wieder Geschichte, lass uns gehen
[Musik]
fünf
Hunde
[Musik]
ist
Sie